foreign
scheme of everything that's going on in
the world feels kind of like a dumb
question wow can I stop you right there
I can almost guarantee that's part of
the problem whatever you're about to ask
me how do I learn to love my body even
when I'm
incredibly overweight like 160 pounds
overweight because I don't love my body
[Music]
what up what up what up what up this is
John from the Dr John Delona show
so glad that you're joining us hanging
out with us if you want to be a part of
the world's greatest mental health and
marriage and parenting podcast and when
I say greatest I don't mean by numbers
or even the quality of the things I
share here I just mean that I just like
to say that over and over again and
hopefully it becomes part of the way you
talk about the show and then we all win
right do you want to be a part of the
greatest mental health and marriage
podcast ever the best in the world give
me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 and I do get a lot of uh
Instagram messages from folks overseas
asking if they can call in yes
absolutely go to John deloney.com ask
and fill out the form and we've made it
work from multiple countries across the
world and actually I love hearing
different perspectives so it's awesome
and um real quick just housekeeping
please go follow us follow me on
Instagram just saying that gives me
hemorrhoids follow me on Instagram and
the tick tocks and all those things and
like And subscribe the show and well you
know that drill just help a brother out
how about that all right let's go to
in Oklahoma what's up Miranda
hey not much how are you Dr John
partying I can't think of a more
Oklahoma name than Orlando that's
fantastic well thank you I think so
that's a compliment you should you
should so what's up
well okay so I have a question and in
the grand scheme of everything that's
going on in the world Phil's kind of
like a dumb question wow can I stop you
right there I can almost guarantee
that's part of the problem whatever
you're about to ask me
I I want you to have permission to own
whatever's
bringing you down
okay you promise and I promise and I
might cry Bring it on I might cry with
you
okay
um my question is this
sorry
how do I learn to love my body even when
sorry don't hey stop apologizing
you're good same team you're my friend
how do I learn to love my body even when
I'm
incredibly overweight like 160 pounds
overweight
because I don't love my body okay
I hate it I hate the way that I look
okay how long have you struggled with
your weight
um my whole life
I'm um
I'm a twin a fraternal twin and
fraternal twin is we all grew up super
skinny and I knew from a
comparison age like whenever I first
started noticing that we look different
um I was the bigger one and actually was
dubbed that as a child like
just at basketball games my friends my
family you know I'm I'm the bigger twin
so my whole life
so most of us who have struggled with
what we see in the mirror
who take her shirts off and look in the
mirror and are grossed out and I've put
myself I'll put myself in that category
I've talked about that here
um
we have an imaginary idea of what we
would look like in another body or if we
would finally just start taking care of
ourselves and stop being so lazy or
whatever other crap we put on a piling
ourselves
walked alongside a literal person
yeah
she was athletic who is the popular girl
who was pretty and and I love her she's
my best friend and she knows all of
these things
um but I I even remember Dr John like at
a young age asking her and then I
actually so I have a twin and then I
have a younger sister that's just 16
months younger so we were pretty much
like triplets
um and she again was skinny tall popular
pretty athletic and I I remember like
probably Junior High asking them
repeatedly like hey ER are you
embarrassed of me like
do I embarrass you or do I
um you know do you do you want to be
seen with me like unprompted would just
ask them that you know of course they'd
be like we don't care like you're you
like you're fine but in my mind
um I was less than yeah
and I still like I I still feel that way
and I and like today's culture you know
like it's like something that and this
has been more recently like I I have
found like these inadvertent thoughts of
comparison
um you watch a commercial you know like
and and I've noticed like there's not
very many fat people in that commercial
you know like or I I'm also I'm a
worship pastor
um so that's always fun because we live
stream services so you know I there's a
video every week of that I if I would
allow myself I go back and watch and I
can critique myself
um but like even
in the realm that I'm in just watching
different videos there's I I I find
myself looking for people who look like
me and
realizing
like there's not and I don't know if um
people do that consciously or
unconsciously but
I immediately do the comparison game and
like okay well that's because you're
you're you your your lifespan yeah so
let's
um
I want you to imagine I'm holding your
hand okay because I want to walk through
a few things and it's going to be
uncomfortable for a minute until it gets
the other side is that okay
absolutely okay
um and I'm going to use some intentional
I'm gonna say things in a in a less than
um
then my normally I try to be pretty
careful with my language I'm going to be
intentional about some things is that
okay
absolutely
um I want you to give me some words that
come to mind when you think of fat
people
the judgments you make just let them
rattle off the top of your head go
yep
uh we're already in it now
um I know I know I'm trying to say it
well my voice doesn't shake um
unattractive
ugly
um
less than like in this as far as like
not as productive not as efficient okay
um people don't like people don't
respect you as much okay
um you want more here here we could and
if you and I were sitting down together
yeah because here's here's what I want
you to put out put out there I do think
you don't like your body I don't make
any mistake about that
I'll even go as far as to say I believe
you that you hate your body
but you hate Miranda
in those words you use to describe all
those other people or the words you use
that's the stories you tell yourself
and I'll also go with you that those are
stories you inhabited that was the area
you breathed that you're the big girl
you're the what and there's a reality to
that you have a different you have a
different genetic makeup your body's
different than your twin sister
right right so you you ha there's a
reality to that and
there was a narrative that you are the
this one and you were one of them not
one of them
to the point that as a young kid
most kids can be so unaware that they're
different
you were not
so somebody somewhere is making it
pretty pretty clear
not 100 and so that story over time
those stories from the kids from your
parents from that Aunt that's just like
oh honey you shouldn't eat that like all
that when you're six for God's sake all
of that those stories
they become stories you tell yourself in
your own voice
and I agree I learned this in a heavy
conversation if you haven't heard my
interview with Sal de Stefano I had him
on my show a while back he's one of the
Mind pump guys
one of the heaviest conversations I've
had around this topic and he said
something that um
I got choked up on the on the interview
because I never occurred to me
he said John you cannot hate yourself
you can't hate your body into better
shape
you can't go to the gym
and try to get rid of how disgusting you
are
you can't look at healthy food and shove
it down your throat because you are so
grossed out by
it doesn't work like that it's a recipe
for Crash and Burn
so you're probably for yo-yo dieting
because that's what I've done my whole
life yes and you know how you can yo-yo
diet because you're
one of the strongest people around
you can grit your teeth
because you're strong you've had to be
your whole life
you're real strong you can grit your
teeth and you can lose 30 pounds but you
still hate Miranda
yep and so it what we're looking for
here is less about how do I not hate my
body
it's how do I make peace with Miranda
and when I decide to go work out
I'm giving Miranda a gift because I love
her
when I decide to not go Crush another
box of whatever which was me last night
I bought seven seven boxes of uh Girl
Scout cookies those evil kids who sell
them one month after everyone's New
Year's resolution
um
but I didn't dominate him last night
based on a conversation I had with Lane
Norton who said hey
you
it's a story you're telling yourself
that you can't help yourself yeah you
can and John my friend is worth more
than that and when he's told me those
words it was like a light bulb came on
and Ryan I do this for a living I've
been having this conversation for 30
years and here I am now
oh yeah I can't hate myself into
long-term Behavior change I love myself
that way same as you can't hate and nag
your husband or wife or girlfriend or
boyfriend into changing it doesn't work
right right so
tell me two or three things that merland
is really amazing at
um
contrary to my
my own beliefs I'm a really good leader
um I am
yeah can we agree on the outset that
your beliefs about yourself are
inaccurate often
100 sweet all right cool that's usually
like seven or eight sessions right there
that's fantastic okay so you know that
your feeling signals can be off or they
can be wrong which is awesome okay so
you're great at worship leading does
that mean you're a great singer a great
guitarist or you're great at bringing
people into community
I can think of few gifts greater to
humanity than someone who can rally
people together for a common purpose
good for you what else
um
I'm very very kind and caring for other
people
um
one of those things I'm good at I've
I've become
I don't know why is this so hard in
every these negative things are so easy
well because our brains are wired for
him and you've had a steady stream of
negativity dumped into your heart mind
your whole life
and negative things are what get us
killed not the positive stuff so our
brains are wired to look for the
negative because it doesn't want to die
yeah and that means we have to work
really hard especially in this world
with all the cell phones and all the
attention and all the video streams that
you're on every week that when our brain
is going there's a threat there's a
threat there's a threat we also have to
counter that with and there's joy and
there's laughter
and there's somebody who's working to
really love herself after a long time of
not having a road map for what that
looks like
here's a way a place I want you to start
a couple of things number one
I want you to start treating my friend
Miranda like you treat those people at
your church
you're kind to them
you welcome them
you laugh and when they say I screwed up
this and I can't believe I slept with so
and so and I did this you say oh my gosh
I love you
and I want you to treat Miranda like
that
and what that means is that's a morning
practice and an evening practice and
you're gonna have to do it double time
because you've been on this track for on
another set of tracks for a long time
foreign because
and don't make a logistical sorry yeah
go ahead like you mean like
I'll tell that to like one of my small
group classes a lot like Go Get It Go
Get a journal today from the store a
brand new one that you've never written
in before
and then and I would put swear words in
it if I wasn't talking to a worship
leader but at the top I would put
why Miranda is worth loving
no not even that Miranda is worth loving
period how about that Miranda I'm sorry
Miranda's worth loving period
and then underneath it write down the
land is somebody who treats people with
dignity and respect Miranda is somebody
who is loved
Miranda is someone who keep going and by
the way you're going to start seeing
that a lot of the stuff is Performance
Based about what you can do for other
people
I want you to get beneath that
is that like part of it because that is
like as you were
I'm good at I mean mean I
a hundred percent or I would not 100 but
probably 97 of all the things that I
think that I'm good at is how it can
make other people's lives better that's
because your whole life you've always
felt worthless and not pretty and not
worthy of being talked to or looked at
or set with and so you created a world
where you could go out
and act your way into worth and value
and God Miranda that's exhausting isn't
it
it is
exhausting
here's the second thing I want you to do
and this is going to be the most
annoying challenge okay and you're gonna
have to practice this
if you and I started salsa dancing
classes we would be terrible right
right and we would know that because we
had never taken salsa dancing before and
we would laugh and stumble around and
fall and our instructor would be like
oh get out of my class and then we'd pay
him and he'd be like all right you can
go back it'd be a whole thing
so as you're practicing this new thing I
wanna I'm gonna get this new task I want
to give you give yourself Grace you
don't know what you're doing you've
never done this before
okay it's gonna be a lot of stumbling
and falling and tripping and it's okay
because it's all new and you'll be like
oh man I screwed that one up have that
attitude about it not well there's
another thing I can put in the Miranda
sucks pile okay
I want you to carry this journal around
with you
everywhere and by the way I got one
right here on my desk right now okay I
want you to carry it around with you and
when you have a negative thought about
Miranda write it down
check every single time it's like taking
a budget except for your thoughts
like you know like you have apps like I
use the every dollar app for my expenses
and every time I buy something it shows
up and it reminds me you just spent this
you just spent this I want you to do
that with your thoughts because what we
have to do in real quick order is take
capture of our thoughts the things that
are circling in your mind all day you're
going to be stunned
at how often you walk by a mirror and
think I'm disgusting or gross or I wear
this shirt or when you're watching
yourself and there could be a thousand
people in your church
being led through a pretty remarkable
worship service and all you can see when
you're watching the tape back is how
unattractive you think you look
foreign
all of that down and here's the second
part of that write it down and challenge
that is this true
and most of the time the answer is no
now I'm also going to tell you hard
truth is this is it okay
you look at a photo of yourself or you
walk by the mirror and you think the
words I need to lose weight you probably
do
but not to be loved
not so that you finally have value
but because you're worth getting up and
your back not hurting and your knees not
hurting and you feeling recklessly
beautiful and you live in to be 80 years
old so you can continue to bring people
together in joy and love and comfort
is that fair
absolutely
yes and so because like I said exercise
becomes a gift
becomes an awesome thing that you give
Miranda taking like working with
somebody to change how you eat all that
stuff like that becomes a gift it
doesn't become a burden or a chore it's
annoying gift I don't like all my gifts
but it's a gift
it's definitely felt like punishment of
course my whole life because you hate
you and you deserve to be punished
right
yep
Miranda that stops today
same team
thank you
will you reach out and call somebody in
your area and tell them
I've hated myself for the last time
yes okay
yes I will
anything I'll be with you every step of
the way okay and again I want you to
hear me say this this isn't a weight
loss Journey
this is going to be a Journey about
rediscovering Miranda and finally giving
that little girl a voice
finally letting that little girl know
that she's loved and valued even though
she doesn't look like her sister
and here's another honest take you may
need to get with a doctor they have had
some advancements in
um obesity care that is unimaginable ten
years ago
it's incredible
yeah okay see I thought about those
things and it's made me think oh well
it's just because you're weak even
though like I've completed 75 hard and I
could do a crossfit workout and I
haven't had sweets since November 1st
like I haven't had any candy or like I
could do things hard things but in my
mind I that's negative thoughts just
start
derailing you can do some hard things
but you can't do the ultimate hard thing
yet
announcement hard thing is forgiving
Miranda for hating herself for so long
and deciding today I'm gonna go do
something different
I took anxiety medication for a couple
of years and it saved my life
and I don't recommend people take
medicine
and I sat at my kitchen table and I wept
I felt like such a freaking loser
and anxiety medication did not cure me
but it did
give me the opportunity to start doing
the things that would heal me
I sit now on the doctor and going
through whether it's medication or
whether so there's all kinds of
different paths here and don't let any
nonsensical influencer or on
YouTube
that's between you and your doctor and
your physician okay
you're not weak you just happen to live
in a sliver of history when we have some
of the most extraordinary advancements
in the history of mankind that can help
people in our situation
and our situations are different
[Music]
Fair
no
starting today you like Miranda and
you're nice to Miranda like I like
Miranda is that fair sure
thank you for being one of the bravest
people I've talked to in a long long
time
anything I can do along the way anytime
you want to call back and say I'm stuck
here I need some help here holler at me
I walk alongside you so grateful for you
we'll be right back
hey deloney here hey you know a while
back Society went off to rails and
people started to see sleep as like an
annoyance it's something in the way
right just chug another energy drink and
keep hustling and grinding my friends
sleep is not the enemy it's essential to
the way our minds and bodies function
and there are several things you can do
right away to start getting better sleep
first lay off the caffeine especially
after like 10 or 11 A.M and ditch the
screens at least an hour before bed and
I recommend getting a great mattress and
you can get a great mattress from my
friends at dreamcloud I speak from
experience here the right mattress can
make a huge difference in your sleep
quality it's why my family sleeps on
dream Cloud their mattresses are
designed to be soft and cool and
supportive so you can sleep comfortably
all night and right now dream cloud is
offering my listeners 25 off your order
plus 50 in additional savings and 500
199 bucks in accessories when you use
promo code John deloney that's cooling
pillows luxury sheets and a mattress
protector so go to dreamcloudsleep.com
and use code John deloney today
all right we're back Jack let's go to
Steven in Ontario what's up Stephen
hey John how's it going partying dude
what are you up to
not too much just enjoying the day
um is it one in Canada right now how
cold is it it's actually been pretty
warm this winter is it's about zero
right now normally be at minus 20
Celsius but uh it's been a warm one this
year so
I don't even know the words you just
said man I don't understand Stephen I
don't understand you all right what's up
uh yeah so I got a relationship question
for you today okay bring it so so for
some context uh I've been in a really
shifting my girlfriend for a bit more
than a year now and uh it's been a great
relationship uh very loving uh great
communication uh kind of ask for
anything better
and after some
internal reflections of thought and kind
of sitting with the feeling for a bit I
think that I am ready to
for having a more serious conversation
about looking at what next steps might
be in terms of Engagement and kind of
planning more seriously what life
together might look like cool now how
old are you
uh I'm 24. I was hoping you're gonna say
16. okay 24. all right cool this would
have been way more fun if you were 16
but okay so 24 awesome
so what you're not gonna help
yeah so the the one thing I'm really
considering with this is that while I
very much have sat with this feeling and
kind of
thought about a lot and
do you really feel it
I think that
you know it's been just over a year and
uh it might be kind of more prudent to
sit with this feeling a bit longer you
know just a few more seasons of Life
under our belt some more experience with
life beside each other before kind of
stepping forward with something like
that and it's kind of dealing with the
conflict of I very much really do feel
that feeling I'm ready for that next
step but also kind of bringing myself in
a bit and just saying hey like times on
your side and we're pretty young and let
these feelings kind of continue to
deepen and sit with them for a bit and
just kind of get your thoughts on that
yeah man thanks for the call
um I think first and foremost you need
to take your feelings and flush them
down the toilet
okay I think you were being led around
by your feelings
and if you set into a long-term
relationship now like make no mistake
like you feel in love and you feel super
you know like all jazzed up to be next
to her like all that's cool like feel
they're awesome right
they make great road signs they make
terrible directions
okay like
because here's what's gonna happen
you're gonna be four or five years into
this thing you're going to be married
and then she'll have a kid and you'll be
figuring X and Y and then you won't
quote unquote feel it anymore
I've been married 20 and a half years I
can guarantee you the feelings come and
go
and at some point if you if you heard my
conversation with Jordan Peterson I made
a covenant I said I would and the times
I have been dangling over the edge to
leave this thing and to walk all that
I've been held back by that one I said I
would
said I would
and so
feelings are fine and good especially at
the beginning
when I begin to look for over time is
are our values as we know them right now
aligned
right and we we very much had have had
those conversations and over time at
over time increasing kind of complexity
and kind of seriousness like and kind of
we've definitely I think has come to the
conclusion that our values very much do
do align but uh I think it's kind of
sitting with each other and kind of
living those values out and kind of
getting consistency over time with that
man you're you're running this thing
like it's a computer program and it
doesn't work like that okay
because my my first impulse is to say
yeah you could go through a lot of life
rigamaroos and experiences and do all
that dating
but that's the stuff that makes
relationships really remarkable and
strong
that's the stuff that you get to share
with other people when you've created
you're committed when you're fully
Anchored In
and
as the great poet Stephen Connell says
love is a promise that comes what comes
I'll be right here
and so more so than any feelings
is this idea that I'm gonna decide every
single morning for the rest of my life
that I'm gonna love you
whether I feel like it whether you're
sick
whether we're broke
whether you've hurt me deeply
every day I will wake up and look across
this room or look at the bed next to me
and say I do
and if you can do that it's game on why
wait
okay if you can't
if you refuse to make that commitment
and her make that commitment
don't do it man you've had a great run
it's been fun you like Dayton it's a
blast
the feelings will come and go my brother
and anybody who gives you some sort of
Matrix
do these 10 things or this is the 15
ways to know if she's the one they're
just smelling you so I mean they're
they're selling your snake oil man it's
nonsense and I I think you've definitely
zeroed in a lot on who I am in that I'm
very much a assistance driven kind of
person I do like to hear it all over you
if you're not a coder yeah man I can
hear it all over not quite but I'm
pretty close exactly so
yeah
okay I'll I'll explain it this way it's
the best way I can explain
foreign
do you know who Dave Ramsey is
oh of course I do okay so I got to you
he's my okay yeah he's my boss right and
he took a couple of uh skydiving this
past summer
there is nothing in my life more
terrifying than Heights for me
I'm talking like I don't like to get on
a ladder I don't like to look over the
edge at a second story like a set of
stairs dude I've trained with Pro MMA
fight I I'm not I've been in active
shooter situation I'm not scared of much
anything I hate heights
hate him and so when he sent the email
around saying hey I'll um I'll pick up
the tab we all go uh skydiving who's in
a couple of my colleagues said I'm out
I'm out and I instantly just went I'm in
and dude I didn't sleep for for however
long I mean I was terrified man but
listen
um it was a spiritual experience for me
and I know that sounds all woo-woo and
lame but here's what it was for me
it showed me this this adventure I had
been on in my marriage where for so many
years I tried to love harder by clamping
down like holding on tighter
holding on to my wife into our values
into our rules into the way things are
in our house and how's our house gonna
and it was this constant revision
are we aligned are we on this thing are
we
and then I jumped out of that plane man
and you just let go
and I had to lean in and Trust the dude
behind me this former Navy SEAL who had
a vested interest in landing safely also
dude it was a total abandonment total
trust like I've never experienced I
gotta trust this guy or I'm dead
gotta do what he says or I'm dead
and it was one of those mad my wife came
with us actually and on our when I got
home we were just talking about it
we both had a conversation about
oh that's belief
is not trying to get all the rules right
it's letting go that's love it's not
trying to take you it's not trying to
suffocate my wife and my family and my
kids it's letting go and when I let go
then she feels safe enough to be so
deeply rooted
in our marriage that she feels safe and
when she feels safe she can breathe when
she can breathe and also see what I'm
saying
it's going to be exactly opposite of
your impulse
I want to control every variable and
make sure every T is crossed every I is
dotted before we do this other thing
because once we do this thing there's no
coming back I'll tell you right now dude
you're gonna cross that line and be like
what happened
right the thing that you can control on
this side of of that experience is
come what come
I will be right here
and I'll spend the rest of my life
trying to meet your needs
will you my love spend the rest of your
life
helping me meet mine
and that's the dance
I think that's variable but um yeah
and I would do anything to have your way
of seeing the World by the way I'm kind
of a chaotic mess so
um you will bring immense value to your
marriage by your hopefully you're
marrying somebody that's gonna drag you
out dancing and you are going to be the
guy that's like how about we pay the
light bill too like I hope that
hopefully that's how you all work right
you have a interesting an incredible
value to relationships I need people
like you for real
um if it wasn't for my wife I would
have an awesome podcast and be homeless
at the same time so you have immense
value but when it comes to this one
decision I'm in I'm in I'm in come what
come I'll be here
and my feelings are going to be a part
of the the signal system but they are
not going to be the direction the
direction is
comma come I'll be right here
I'm not going anywhere
best love and I hate to say this so
crassly but my brother
loves a choice every day for the rest of
your life we'll be right back
hey good folks John deloney here
I fell through a glitch in The Matrix
this is my job I get to have this show
do this show walk alongside each one of
you as a career this is what I do and I
have a blast doing it and me and the
team were so thankful for all of you for
being a part of our show whether you're
one of the original 17 or you're one of
the millions that's come since then we
are so grateful for you and we want to
put together the best possible show that
we can so if you're one of The Originals
or if you're brand new we want your
feedback tell us what you love about the
show what you hate about the show what
you'd like to see more of what you like
to hear more of and what you want us to
never do again you can email us at
askjohn ramseysolutions.com that's
askjohn ramseysolutions.com with your
feedback thank you for being such an
important part of the show rock on
let's go to Chicago
and talk to Aaron what's up hey Hey Ron
what's up
hey Dr John how you doing good you doing
well
to win well excellent thanks so much for
uh taking my call appreciate it you got
it man what's happening
Hey so uh just reaching out to you today
just uh for some guidance in regarding a
hard conversation that eventually got to
happen with my mom
um just to give you some background
information for you so
um my father passed away suddenly in
December of 2021. oh man I'm sorry and
yeah no thanks oh what was his name
um his name was uh Leon was he pretty
cool
yeah man he was a dust
I miss him every day his name was Leon
did y'all used to watch those Leon
commercials together remember those
oh I don't think so I don't remember
those their ESPN Leon don't can't do
everything you remember those they were
fantastic
oh I don't know tell me something that
was amazing about your dad
um he could just like do so many things
um he was a handy guy he I mean he
helped me like redo my kitchen he
refinished like four or five basements
in his lifetime
um
you see one of those you see one of
those hardcore
um Union or almost Union Chicago guys
that didn't always say the word I love
you but you would wake up at 6am and
they're pulling your cabinets down to
replace them for you
uh no he wasn't a union guy he just uh
he loved to like just stay busy and work
with his hands and just during his
retirement he just was a handy guy and
was painting walls for people and
installing flooring and
um just you know he was uh 75 years old
and he could do like circles around 65
year olds at times so he sounds like he
uh
he sounds like he
loved well
totally absolutely what a cool I can't I
can think of I hope I hope my kids say
that about me my dad was nuts and he was
kind of a but he loved well that's
awesome all right so tell me about your
question hard conversation you gotta
have
so um
uh like I said you know just uh it was a
shock to us all and um didn't see it
coming and
um so in 2019 my mom and dad moved to
the home where they current where my mom
currently lives and um it's a bigger
home with about you know 26 2800 square
feet got three-car garage decent size
you know residential lot
and um you know my mom she's she's
healthy at this point she's she's active
I mean my mom's incredible She's Not
Afraid of hard work she cuts the lawn
she shovels the snow she's uh she's the
active healthy 73 year old
um as far as I know and
um just like you know in time just it's
how big the home is and where she lives
just you know my sister and I really
liked her to consider you know just
sizing down just to you know for her own
health and safety and
um just
um also too you know I think it would be
a stress relieve her for her as well
but uh at the same time I think
um
just in previous conversations like
broad conversations she's made the
comment like oh I don't think I could
move again and and things like that and
being that it's been over a year now
that my dad has passed just gotta look
ahead and
have the conversation and just to find
out
um if she'd be willing and just how to
do that
so that that's really like um
question and your mom I'll tell you this
your mom is lucky to have a couple of
kids who love her so much it's awesome
it's awesome yeah thank you
um all right so I'm going to tell you
some hard truths and then give you maybe
like a plan is that cool sure yeah all
this I'm just rattling off top of my
head here so it may be worth I don't
want it any other way the free advice
um it sounds like by the way you just
described this
that this move would be more for you and
your sister and not your mom at this
point
or this move would alleviate your
attention and your fear and your angst
not your moms
yeah and I know that sucks to say that
out loud
and you know another thing it's
something that I forgot to mention is
um I mean like I said she's she's
healthy I do know that
um she does kind of have like weaker
bones where she goes in like
monthly temporarily and she's having
like injections done to kind of make her
bones stronger osteoporosis
um yeah she does take like I think
medication for that okay and she has
mentioned to us
um at one point that she was going down
um like uh some steps it was just a two
or three step sets in the house and she
did fall and she didn't like tell us
till two weeks later and he's like Mom
what the heck come on how was this when
it happens so does she still have
um
inside that home
is there still pictures of your dad
everywhere are his clothes still there
uh no his clothes is not there
um yes there are pictures
um I mean his his tools and things are
are still there
um that's again something that we're
gonna have to like tackle at some point
and figure out
um so here my bigger question is for
your mom
is your dad still inside this home
and um that might be a that's a
different conversation than hey let's
make your life easier
the other conversation is as a family
we've grieved dad for a year and it's
been hard and we miss him and I can't
even I mean
you still can't even talk about them
without getting choked up because you
loved him so much and he loved you so
much
and
we gotta let that go
and that doesn't mean dad doesn't live
with us in our hearts forever and dad
hasn't made a ripple through time that
will continue to to Ripple through
generations and generations on
right we gotta we gotta let that go
and that's a different conversation than
hey Mom what if you didn't have to
shovel the driveway would that sound
awesome see what I'm saying yeah right
so
I would approach so I'm just going to
tell you this how I would approach this
if I were you okay okay if this was my
situation and my dad just suddenly
passed away my dad's like your dad he
loves recklessly he's a big personality
he's loud and Goofy and uh
um just amazing guy and if he's suddenly
just overnight went away
right so I look up a year later and I
flew to Texas to sit with my mom and
um
what I would say is
mom this house looks like and feels like
so much work
and I want you to hear from me
I want nothing but peace and laughter
and joy for you for the rest of the time
we have you
the moment you're ready to do the hard
work of digging in and selling some of
this stuff and selling the house and
moving to a patio home or moving in our
basement the dad refinished whatever
that looks like
I want you to know we are I'm ready to
rock and roll by your side
and so it's more forming an alliance and
less
pressuring her
more I'm on your team and when you're
ready we will come in with our goggles
on like the home repair shows we'll be
ready to rock and roll
um and less about I'm your son but now
I'm taking the role of your dad I'm
gonna tell you what to do
right
you see see how that's a little bit
different
totally yeah how does your you know your
mom way better night I mean I don't
remember how do you how does that how
does that conversation land with her
yeah you know I think um
just you know coming from our heart and
approaching it that way it may
um
turn on a light bulb and make it all
your problem make it a hundred like Mom
I worry about you you're a gangster like
you're out shoveling the snow and doing
flips off the roof into the yard like
you're awesome I am struggling
yeah and maybe that's a a an opportunity
for her to give herself some purpose
well I gotta make my son feel better
again like who knows but make it your
problem at this point now she breaks a
hip
she's unable to move you go by to see
her in the yard is four feet tall and
there's snow everywhere and she can't
get out of the house that's a totally
different conversation
right that's the conversation folks have
with their 90 year old dads and they say
Dad I'm taking the car keys you can't
drive anymore you're not safe
right those are hard conversations man
um and you hope that parents will
volunteer right the same as old boxers
dude they have to be told by their
friends and managers and loved ones I'm
not taking your money anymore you got to
stop very few boxers are like all right
all right it's time for me to go you
don't still do that right right and so
that's hard
um I would make this all on you at this
point you and your sister mom we're
worrying about you we love you we want
you to know that you've got our
permission
to let this house go to let Dad go be
with whatever wherever he is and us to
create a new life with the with the
years we got left
gotcha
nope uh that's solid thanks so much yeah
man will you do me a huge favor let me
know how that conversation goes
yeah I will absolutely and one more one
more tiny little piece and I'll I'll let
you go
don't don't spring this on her set it up
okay right no so I'd let her know hey
we're gonna come over we're gonna talk
about future stuff
and it's also a great time to talk about
a will
like does she have a will did your dad
have a will be good yeah do you know
where it is and all that
I do yeah great awesome awesome awesome
um yeah your parents sound more Amazing
by the second dude that's awesome
um but if that's when you have those
conversations do we do we know
everything is like I just want to make
sure that we're planning for the future
so we can best love you and take care of
you in the coming years and we're we're
we got caught off guard with Dad it was
a shock
we're always get we're going to be
shocked no matter what but we want to
make sure we've got all our ducks in a
row and totally
I can't sleep at night because I think
you're gonna do some results down the
stairs
she's a good 80 year old
snow shoveling Chicago woman she'll
think that's hilarious all right
yes she will
she sounds awesome hey man um it's been
an honor to talk to you let me know how
that conversation goes um shoot us an
email or give us a call back in and I'll
update the audience here but I want to
hear how that conversation goes my guess
is
she's gonna say thank you for thinking
about us
and not make any decisions for a minute
and then all of a sudden you're gonna
get a call out of the blue that she says
hey it's time let's list the house
and then you're gonna have to go through
your grieving process because it's going
to be very real but that's something
y'all can all do together
life after loss is so hard and y'all are
lucky that you have each other
stay together we'll be right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
ever last year you took a leave to
follow her tour around which was caused
that weird but it's cool
Front Row Joe
have you not been to a concert see her
oh my gosh I can't believe you lied to
America today's song of the day is
written by Kelly's favorite singer ever
Miley Cyrus
she actually hanging from her uh
rearview mirror in her car is just a
miniature little wrecking ball instead
of the dice she just has a little
wrecking ball Kelly loves it
songs called flowers and it goes like
this we were good we were gold
kind of dream that can't be sold we were
right till we weren't built a home and
watched it burn I didn't want to leave
you I didn't want to lie I started to
cry but then I remembered I can buy
myself flowers and write my name in the
sand and talk to myself for hours say
things you don't understand I can take
myself dancing I can hold my own hand I
can love me better than you can
[Music]
harsh
bring it Miley now I know why you love
her so much so much Kelly man hey we'll
see you soon good folks
[Music]